Speaking of Psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning one of our favorite episodes from the past. In July 2021, I talked to psychologist Lisa Orbe Austin and Kevin Coakley about imposter phenomenon, what it is and how people can overcome it. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of Psychology, we'll be back with new episodes next week. Thank you for listening. Do you ever feel like a fake? like you're not really qualified for the job you're doing despite your achievements and credentials, or like you've just lucked your way into whatever professional or academic success you enjoy,
《心理学话语》栏目正在进行暑期休假，因此我们重新播出了过去最受欢迎的一期节目。在2021年7月，我与心理学家丽莎·奥尔韦-奥斯汀和凯文·科克利探讨了冒名顶替现象，包括它是什么以及人们如何克服它。希望大家喜欢这期来自档案库的节目。《心理学话语》将于下周携新节目回归。感谢您的收听。你是否觉得自己像个冒牌货？尽管你取得了成就和资历，却觉得自己根本不具备胜任目前工作的资格，或者觉得你只是靠运气才获得了如今的职业或学术成功，
but you're just one mistake away from being found out for the fraud you really are. If so, you're not alone. Those are signs of imposter phenomenon, also called imposter syndrome. While estimates vary, some research suggests that up to 70% or more of people experience imposter feelings at some point in their lives. So where do these feelings come from? Who is most likely to experience imposter phenomenon? What repercussions can it have in people's personal and professional lives? And if you're troubled by imposter feelings, what can you do to address them and keep them from holding you back?
但你距离被戳穿其实只差一个错误，露出你真正是个骗子的马脚。如果是这样，你并不孤单。这些都是冒名顶替现象（也称为冒名顶替综合征）的迹象。虽然估计数字有所不同，但一些研究表明，高达70%或更多的人在其生命中的某个时刻都经历过冒名顶替的感觉。那么，这些感觉从何而来？谁最容易经历冒名顶替现象？它会在人们的个人和职业生活中产生什么影响？如果你正被冒名顶替的感觉所困扰，你能做些什么来解决它们并防止它们阻碍你前进？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Lisa Orbay-Austin, a counseling psychologist in Korea, career coach in New York City, where she focuses on helping clients with career advancement, career transitions, and leadership development. Her book, Own Your Greatness, Overcome Imposter Syndrome, Beat Self-Doubt, and Succeed in Life,
欢迎收听《心理学话语》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我们有两位嘉宾。第一位是丽莎·奥尔韦-奥斯汀博士，她是一名在韩国接受培训的咨询心理学家，也是纽约市的职业教练，专注于帮助客户实现职业晋升、职业转型和领导力发展。她的书《拥有你的伟大，克服冒名顶替综合征，战胜自我怀疑，在生活中取得成功》，
offers readers advice based on decades of research, as well as her own experience helping clients recognize and overcome imposter phenomenon. Our second guest is Dr. Kevin Coakley, a professor of educational psychology at the University of Texas at Austin. Dr. Coakley studies African American psychology, and he is, particularly interested in understanding the psychological and environmental factors that affect African-American student achievement. As part of that work, he has explored the imposter phenomenon and its relationship to mental health and academic outcomes among ethnic minority students. Thank you both for joining me today. Thank you. Thank you for having us,
为读者提供了基于数十年研究的建议，以及她自己帮助客户识别和克服冒名顶替现象的经验。我们的第二位嘉宾是凯文·科克利博士，他是德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校的教育心理学教授。科克利博士研究非裔美国人心理学，他对理解影响非裔美国学生学业成就的心理和环境因素特别感兴趣。作为该工作的一部分，他探讨了冒名顶替现象及其与少数族裔学生心理健康和学业成果的关系。非常感谢两位今天做客我的节目。谢谢。谢谢邀请我们，
let's start briefly by talking about the words we're going to use. In the introduction a moment ago, I used the term imposter phenomenon, but many of our listeners may be more familiar with the term imposter syndrome. Are these just two different names for the same thing? In my own language, I use the language of the imposter phenomenon, which of course is the language that was used by Pauline Kleins and Suzanne Iams when they introduced terminology to the literature. We see in sort of popular discourse now the words, the imposter syndrome, which is more popular than the phrase imposter phenomenon. I tend to stay away from. the imposter syndrome, because of the word syndrome itself,
让我们先简单谈谈我们要使用的词汇。刚才在介绍中，我使用了“冒名顶替现象”这个词，但我们的许多听众可能对“冒名顶替综合征”这个词更熟悉。这只是同一事物的两个不同名称吗？在我自己的语言中，我使用“冒名顶替现象”这一说法，这当然是保琳·克兰斯和苏珊·伊姆斯在文献中引入该术语时使用的说法。我们现在在某种程度上看到大众话语中使用“冒名顶替综合征”这个词，它比“冒名顶替现象”这个短语更受欢迎。我倾向于避开“冒名顶替综合征”，因为“综合征”这个词本身，
has such a clinical sort of orientation and innuendo. And it was not, again, it is not a syndrome in a classic sense of something that is, that is diagnosable the way that we think about sort of diagnosis as psychologists. So I tend to use a word imposter phenomenon, but I recognize that in terms of popular discourse, the phrase imposter syndrome is much more known. Yeah, and I agree with Kevin that in essence, in the book I sort of talk about the fact that, you know, you know, it is initially coined as imposter phenomenon, doctors, Clance and Iams, the originators of the concept,
带有如此临床的导向和暗示。而且它并不是一个经典意义上的综合征，不像我们心理学家所认为的那种可以被诊断出来的东西。所以我倾向于使用“冒名顶替现象”这个词，但我承认在大众话语中，“冒名顶替综合征”这个短语更为人熟知。是的，我同意凯文的看法，本质上，我在书中谈到过这样一个事实，你知道，它最初是被命名为冒名顶替现象的，克兰斯和伊姆斯医生，也就是这个概念的创始人们，
were very clear and never using the word syndrome and not wanting to go in that direction because of the medicalized and pathologizing kind of connotation to it. However, in my work, I often use syndrome because that's how people in popular culture identify it and don't identify it with phenomenon. And so it's easier for people to kind of search and find and connect to the idea. But in terms of it is fairly interchangeable, but I completely agree with Kevin around the concept. So as you said, there's no official diagnosis of imposter phenomenon. It's not in the diagnostic and statistical manual. It's not in the ICD, the international classifications of disease. Do either of you believe that it should be a formal diagnosis? And if so, would that be helpful or harmful?
非常明确地从不使用“综合征”这个词，并且由于它所具有的医疗化和病理化色彩，而不想朝那个方向发展。然而，在我的工作中，我经常使用“综合征”，因为大众文化中的人们就是这样识别它的，而不是通过“现象”来识别。因此，人们更容易搜索、发现并与这个概念建立联系。但就这两个词而言，它们在很大程度上是可以互换的，我完全同意凯文对这个概念的看法。正如你所说，对冒名顶替现象并没有官方诊断。它不在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中，也不在世界卫生组织的国际疾病分类（ICD）中。你们俩是否认为它应该成为一个正式的诊断？如果是的话，这会有帮助还是会有害？
Well, I, again, I don't think that there should be a former diagnosis. I agree with Dr. Orbae Austin that that in some ways sort of medicalizes and pathologizes a term that is really rooted in many ways to reactions to external social stimuli. And so I think that to suggest that it be sort of a former diagnosis really is misplaced and does a disservice to not recognizing the external environments and the other. the sort of stimuli that really are imposing upon people that help sort of exacerbate their feelings of imposterism. Yeah, I agree. I think there are many correlates of imposter syndrome to mental health issues. So, you know, people often have higher levels of anxiety or depression. There are other, like, really diagnostic conditions that do result from the experience. But the experience, I think, of it in and of itself probably doesn't require that. And I think, you know, if you think about diagnostic conditions and this idea that it's sort of impacting your
嗯，我再次认为不应该有一个正式的诊断。我同意奥尔韦-奥斯汀博士的观点，在某些方面，这使得一个在很大程度上根源于对外部社会刺激反应的词语被医疗化和病理化了。因此，我认为建议将其作为一种正式诊断实在是不合时宜，而且无助于认识到那些对人们施加影响并加剧其冒名顶替感的外部环境和其他刺激因素。是的，我同意。我认为冒名顶替综合征与心理健康问题有很多相关性。所以，你知道，人们通常会有更高水平的焦虑或抑郁。还有其他一些确实由这种经历导致的真正可诊断的状况。但我想，这种经历本身可能并不需要诊断。并且我认为，如果你考虑诊断状况以及它会影响你的
social, relational, academic functioning, a lot of people with imposter syndrome are actually doing quite well. And so, yes, there are internal, you know, potential correlates, but not for everyone. And it sort of, it varies. And so I think it's really not necessarily, it doesn't necessarily have to be a diagnostic condition to receive intervention, support, you know, other things, be able to see it as a valid experience. Given the amount of coverage that this phenomenon has had in the mainstream media, I think many people's general impression is that imposter phenomenon is a bigger problem for women. Does the research bear that out?
社会、人际、学术功能这一观念，许多患有冒名顶替综合征的人实际上表现得相当好。所以，是的，存在内在的、潜在的相关性，但并非对每个人都如此。而且这种情况有所不同。因此，我认为它不一定非要成为一种诊断状况才能接受干预、支持和其他帮助，或者才能被视为一种有效的经历。鉴于主流媒体对这一现象的大量报道，我认为许多人总的印象是，冒名顶替现象对女性来说是一个更大的问题。研究是否证实了这一点？
Dr. Orbea Austin is, could you answer that? Who is most likely to experience imposter phenomena, imposter feelings? Well, I think, like, I'll also ask Kevin for his opinion, Dr. Coghleys for his opinion, but in my understanding of the research, I feel like there hasn't been a conclusive point. on whether or not one gender experiences it more than another. There isn't conclusive research to suggest, yes, women experience it more than others. I think because it was initially studied with women, I think people then feel like, oh, this is a women's issue.
奥尔韦-奥斯汀博士，您能回答一下吗？谁最容易经历冒名顶替现象、冒名顶替的感觉？嗯，我想，我会同时询问凯文的意见，也就是科克利博士的意见，但在我对研究的理解中，我觉得关于某种性别是否比另一种性别经历得更多，并没有一个确凿的结论。没有确凿的研究表明，是的，女性比其他人经历得更多。我想，因为它最初是以女性为研究对象进行研究的，所以人们随后会觉得，哦，这是一个女性的问题。
And I think, you know, some of the research shows that men experience it somewhat differently. And there's a lot of room for discussion around gender diversity and gender expression. We don't have a lot of research around that itself. But I think it's really important to note that sometimes men experience this in what looks like a different way. And so I think it oftentimes then goes a little bit under-reported in terms of their experience of it. Is sexism a factor here? I mean, is it just the fact that women often feel like we have to perform so much better than men? Fred Astaire did, he was phenomenal, but, you know, his partner danced backwards in high heels. I mean, we always have to be a little bit
而且我认为，你知道，一些研究表明，男性的经历在某种程度上有所不同。围绕性别多样性和性别表达，还有很大的讨论空间。我们周围没有太多关于这本身的研究。但我认为非常重要的一点是要注意，有时男性经历这种感觉的方式看起来有所不同。因此，我认为在他们的经历方面，往往会被低估。性别歧视是这里的因素吗？我的意思是，这难道仅仅是因为女性经常觉得我们必须比男性表现得更好吗？弗雷德·阿斯泰尔很棒，但你知道，他的舞伴穿着高跟鞋在倒着跳舞。我的意思是，我们总是必须比
better than Ginger Rogers. I lost her name for a minute. Is that part of why women may feel it more acutely. And even Dr. Coakley, ethnic minorities. I mean, the same thing. You know, you have to, because you study that area, you have to perform that much higher a level in order to be taken seriously in many situations. Yeah, no, I would agree with what Dr. Orbe also said, that in the original context, the focus was on women and women who were, you know, very successful. And I think that Dr. Clancy and Dr. Iames perhaps thought that it was, you know, more salient with women, but the research itself has been equivocal. In my own research, I have conducted studies where, you know, some studies, you know, women have reported higher imposter feelings,
金杰·罗杰斯做得更好一点。（我有一会儿忘她的名字了。）这是否是女性可能更强烈地感受到它的原因之一？还有科克利博士，少数族裔也是如此。我的意思是，同样的事情。你知道，因为你研究这个领域，你必须在许多情况下表现出更高的水平才能被认真对待。是的，不，我同意奥尔韦-奥斯汀博士所说的话，即在最初的背景下，重点是女性以及那些非常成功的女性。我认为克兰斯博士和伊姆斯博士可能认为这对女性来说更为突出，但研究本身一直是不明确的。在我自己的研究中，我进行过这样的研究，你知道，在一些研究中，女性报告了更高的冒名顶替感，
but in other studies, there's not been any significant sex difference at all. So, and that's, that's the case with other studies that have reported on imposter phenomenon of finding. So, so the findings are equivocal. What I will say, and I agree again with Dr. to Orby-Aa-Austen that you do see that the way that imposter feelings manifest themselves takes on a very gendered sort of approach. So for example, I have found in one of my studies looking at academic outcomes that imposter feelings were much more salient for women with concerning GPA compared to men. There was no significant mean difference. They both reported significant, similar levels of imposterism, but its implications for academic outcomes, in this
但在其他研究中，并没有发现任何显著的性别差异。所以，其他关于冒名顶替现象发现的研究也是如此。因此，研究结果是不明确的。我要说的是，我再次同意奥尔韦-奥斯汀博士的观点，你会发现冒名顶替感显现的方式呈现出一种非常具有性别特征的方法。例如，我在一项研究中发现，在观察学业成果时，对于女性来说，GPA（平均绩点）相关的冒名顶替感比男性更为明显。均值没有显著差异。她们都报告了显著的、相似水平的冒名顶替感，但它对学业成果（在此
case, GPA, was definitely gendered. And so that's the way that I think it's best to think about any sort of potential gender differences involving imposterousal feelings. And then regarding ethnic minorities, absolutely, I became interested in the area because of my own research on the psychosocial experiences of African-recogn students and other BIP students. And when I came across the imposterivism literature, I was fascinated because there had been relatively little work done on students of color. And so I saw where it would be immediately applicable to the work that I was doing. And it turns out that I was right because many, many BIPAC students report feelings of imposterism in predominantly white educational spaces. And so I think that there is definitely a very strong
情况下为GPA）的影响绝对具有性别特征。因此，我认为这是思考涉及冒名顶替感的任何潜在性别差异的最好方式。至于少数族裔，绝对是这样，我之所以对这个领域产生兴趣，是因为我对自己关于非裔学生和其他亚裔、拉美裔等少数族裔学生心理社会经历的研究。当我偶然读到有关冒名顶替主义的文献时，我感到非常着迷，因为此前针对有色人种学生的研究相对较少。所以我看到它将立即适用于我正在做的工作。事实证明我是对的，因为许许多多的亚裔、拉美裔等少数族裔学生在主要是白人的教育空间中报告了冒名顶替的感觉。因此，我认为这里绝对有一个非常强烈的
connection there. Yeah, and I think I'll add to that in the sense that we talk about this in our work, and our training is about sort of the double impact of imposter syndrome for women, for people of color, of this experience of having these internal feelings, like, I might be a fraud. Like, I don't know if I belong here. I might be incompetent. And then this external communication happening
联系。是的，我想我会对此补充一点，我们在工作中谈论过这一点，我们的培训是关于女性、有色人种所受到的冒名顶替综合征的双重影响，这种体验既有内在的感觉，比如，我可能是一个骗子。就像，我不知道我是否属于这里。我可能无能。然后还有来自外界的外部交流，
from the world being like, male, maybe you don't belong here. Maybe you got here because of a diversity program. Maybe you're not good enough. And so as you're working on it and trying to believe in your competence and skills, you're getting these external messages that are reinforcing the imposter syndrome,
来自世界的信号，比如：也许你不属于这里。也许你来到这里是因为多元化项目。也许你不够优秀。因此，当你努力去相信自己的能力和技能时，你却在接收到这些强化冒名顶替综合征的外部信息，
which I think makes it more difficult to overcome, because you're getting these additional signals like, hey, maybe you are. And I think, you know, as a result of systems of oppression and other things, they kind of benefit from you maintaining your imposter syndrome. So, you know, I think it's really important to kind of recognize that it can be experienced very different and different populations. Well, let's talk for a minute about how imposter feelings affect people's lives. Dr. Orbe Austin, how do you see it affecting your clients in terms of their career paths and the career choices that they make? Well, I mean, I think it's interesting because I think many of them, I deal with mostly, I work a lot with women, and I think many of them, you know, what the literature finds around women
这使得它更难克服，因为你正在接收到这些额外的信号，比如，嘿，也许你确实是。并且我认为，由于压迫系统和其他事情的结果，他们某种程度上受益于你维持你的冒名顶替综合征。所以，你知道，我认为真正重要的是要认识到，它在不同人群中的体验可能非常不同。好吧，让我们花一会儿时间讨论一下冒名顶替感是如何影响人们的生活的。奥尔韦-奥斯汀博士，您是如何看待它在职业道路和所做职业选择方面对您的客户产生影响的？嗯，我的意思是，我认为这很有趣，因为我认为他们中的许多人，我主要接触的人，我与很多女性合作，并且我认为她们中的许多人，你知道，文献围绕女性发现的
and some of the ways in which they deal with it is that they're counterphobic, and so they actually face the thing that they're afraid of. And so I don't see them not achieving. I do see them struggling to advocate for themselves in terms of salary, to sometimes feel like they can find other opportunities elsewhere, feeling like maybe this is the only place that will really appreciate me and sort of getting stuck in places. I find it they often struggle with, you know, advocating for promotion and other things. And also, too, I think also in management, struggle with delegation and and micromanagement feeling like their direct reports are direct reflection on them and they don't want to be exposed. And so I do see it
以及她们应对它的某些方式是，她们具有反式恐惧（counterphobic），因此她们实际上直面自己害怕的事情。所以我并没有看到她们没有取得成就。我确实看到她们在薪资方面为自己争取权益时举步维艰，有时觉得她们无法在其他地方找到其他机会，觉得也许这里是唯一真正欣赏我的地方，从而陷入某些地方无法自拔。我发现她们经常在为晋升和其他事情争取权益时苦苦挣扎。而且，我也认为在管理方面，在授权和微观管理方面也很挣扎，觉得她们直接管辖的下属直接反映了她们自己，她们不想被暴露。所以我确实看到了
and come up in these different ways. And Dr. Coakley, how does it affect achievement and mental health in the students you've studied? Well, it's interesting because with students of color, I see them really sometimes struggling with acknowledging to other people that they have these feelings. So what ends up happening is that BIPOC students in predominantly white spaces are well aware of the perception that they, by son, that they don't belong there, that they're simply there because of affirmative action. And so they want to sort of prove to others and to themselves that though I belong here because of my achievements and because I am meritorious. but yet they still have this little voice that says, you know, maybe you really were just simply a product of a firm perfection.
它以这些不同的方式出现。科克利博士，它如何影响您所研究的学生的成就和心理健康？嗯，这很有趣，因为对于有色人种学生，我看到他们有时很难向其他人承认自己有这些感觉。所以最后发生的情况是，主要由白人构成的空间中的有色人种学生非常清楚这样一种看法，即他们由于某种原因不属于这里，他们来这里只是因为平权行动。因此，他们想向别人证明，也向自己证明，虽然我属于这里是因为我的成就，因为我有功绩。
So this causes, in addition to all the other sort of stressors that all college students experience, this added sort of what I call this sort of like racialized expression of imposterism is an additional burden and stress on students of color, which ends up sort of taking a toll on them emotionally and their well-being. Now, I will say this, that it's interesting because when you look at, and there's not a lot of empirical data right now to support this, but when you look at the sort of effect on the actual achievement, you'll see that in some cases, I mean, this is perhaps more anecdotal than supported by data, but it seems that individuals who have imposter feelings are also performing in some cases at even higher levels. In other words, they work so hard to, try to counter any sort of perceptions that they don't belong there, that they might end up doing, you know, relatively well, but suffer from sort of, you know, mental health sort of challenges. And so certainly I see, you know, with students of color, them also sort of overachieving, overperforming, trying to sort of counter what they believe to be perceptions about their worthiness of being there.
但这引发了除了所有其他所有大学生都经历的压力之外的额外压力，这种我称之为这种冒名顶替主义的种族化表达，对有色人种学生来说是一个额外的负担和压力，最终在情感和福祉上对他们造成了损害。现在，我要说的是，这很有趣，因为当你看到——现在没有太多的实证数据来支持这一点——但当你看到对实际成就的影响时，你会发现，在某些情况下，我的意思是这可能比数据支持的更多是轶事，但似乎有冒名顶替感的人在某些情况下甚至在以更高的水平表现。换句话说，他们非常努力地工作，试图反驳任何关于他们不属于这里的看法，以至于他们最后可能做得相对较好，但却遭受了某种心理健康方面的挑战。因此，我当然看到，对于有色人种学生来说，他们也存在过度成就、过度表现，试图反驳他们认为别人对他们是否有资格留在那里的看法。
So they might, on the one hand, look, you know, pretty good on paper in terms of their academic achievements, but they may be suffering from mental health decline. You've both written about your personal experiences with imposter phenomenon. Can you talk about those a little bit how those experiences have informed the work that you do? I mean, for me, it's what drew me to the work, actually, is my own personal experience with imposter syndrome. I've probably had a very different research path early on, and I think, and writing path. But I think that, you know, having experienced it very, very, like pretty impactfully. I mean, I talk about in a TEDx talk and I was in a particularly bad job after I graduated
因此，一方面他们在纸面上看起来相当不错，就他们的学业成就而言，但他们可能正在遭受心理健康下降的痛苦。你们两人都写过关于你们自己对冒名顶替现象的个人经历。你们能稍微谈谈这些经历吗？这些经历是如何为你们所从事的工作提供信息的？我的意思是，对我来说，正是它吸引我从事这项工作，实际上是我自己对冒名顶替综合征的个人经历。我早期可能走了一条非常不同的研究道路，并且我认为，还有写作道路。但我认为，你知道，经历过它非常非常有影响力的事情。我的意思是，我在一个TEDx演讲中谈到了这一点，而且我在毕业后曾在一个特别糟糕的工作中
from my PhD program and I was working for a pretty oppressive boss and felt stuck. I felt stuck in a very really, I felt like stuck in a way I couldn't apply for other jobs. I couldn't talk to people. I was really, really stuck in this job where he was really just making sure that I didn't go anywhere He wasn't necessarily ever complimenting me or ever saying I did a good job, but making sure that I felt really underwater. And it wasn't until I was in a meeting, and I show this often that I was in a meeting. It was an all-female senior staff, and there was music playing in the background, and someone said, what is this music that's playing? And he said, it's music to soothe the savage breast.
从我的博士项目开始，当时我为一位相当压迫人的老板工作，觉得被困住了。我觉得自己被困在一种非常真实的状态中，无法申请其他工作，无法与人交流。我真的、真的很痛苦地被困在这份工作中，他一心只想确保我哪里也去不了，他从来不表扬我，也从不说我做得好，而是让我感到自己快要被淹没了。直到有一次开会，我经常讲述这件事：当时我在开一个会，与会者全都是女性高管，背景音乐放着音乐，有人问这放的是什么音乐？他说，这是安抚野兽的音乐。
And in that one moment, I sort of, like, woke up, and I was like, what am I doing to myself? And why am I here? and why am I putting up with this? And it was all the imposter stuff. I didn't feel good enough. I didn't feel worthy. I didn't feel like I deserved anything. I didn't, you know,
就在那一瞬间，我好像醒悟了，心想：我对自己的所作所为到底是什么？我为什么在这里？我为什么要忍受这一切？这其实都是冒名顶替心态在作祟。我觉得自己不够优秀，觉得不配得到这一切，觉得我不配拥有任何东西，我当时……
and I just really decided I didn't want to live like that anymore. And I actually quit the job on that Monday and left. And started my practice, like soon after and finally took my licensing exam, did all the things that I was actually not executing on it that were related to my dreams and my goals and my wishes. So for me, like the way it connects for me is that, you know, I feel a very disconcern. distinct passion for making other people aware of how it operates in their lives and helping them, you know, be free of it so that they can feel like they can live in their dreams and not feel the oppression of it. And I think, you know, like Kevin was mentioning, I think from an external
我真的下定决心，再也不想那样生活了。实际上，我在那个星期一就辞职离开了。不久后我就开办了自己的诊所，终于去考了执照，把那些我一直没有去执行的、与我的梦想、目标和愿望相关的事情都做了。对我来说，它与我的联系在于，我产生了一种非常清晰的热情，那就是让其他人意识到它如何在他们的生活中运作，并帮助他们摆脱它，这样他们就能觉得能够活在梦想中，而不会感受到它的压迫。而且我认为，正如凯文刚才提到的，从外部层面来看……
level, I don't think anyone would have been looking at my career going, God, that's a disaster. But for me, it felt like that's what was happening. And I wasn't living in the things that I wanted to be doing for myself. And so that's how it connects for me. Dr. Coakley, what about you? Well, you know, it's interesting. When I give talks to students about my own path to sort of where I've gotten professionally, I always share with them the stories of some of my struggles as an undergraduate student and how, you know, I, you know, had an academic scholarship. I was immediately placed on academic probation after my first semester in college. And just so I talk about sort of how I struggle, you know, as a student. academically. And then when students sort of see where I am now and professionally, they're always amazed. But what the where it is relevant for me even today is that in spite of all of the accolades and things that I've been able to accomplish in my career, I still harbor vestiges of imposterism. And it may seem crazy because, you know, I've, you know, I've done pretty well as an
我认为不会有人看着我的职业生涯说：“天哪，那是一场灾难。”但对我来说，感觉事情就是这样的。我并没有过着自己想要为自己做的事情的生活。所以这就是它与我的联系。科克利博士，你呢？嗯，你知道的，这很有趣。当我给学生们做关于我如何走到今天这一职业道路的演讲时，我总是和他们分享我作为本科生时的一些挣扎，比如，你知道的，我曾获得学术奖学金，但在大学第一个学期结束后，我立刻就被留校察看了。我只是谈到了我作为一个学生在学术上是如何挣扎的。然后，当学生们看到我现在的职业成就时，他们总是感到惊讶。但它对我的现实意义，甚至在今天依然存在，那就是：尽管我在职业生涯中获得了所有的荣誉和成就，我内心仍然潜藏着冒名顶替综合征的痕迹。这听起来可能有点疯狂，因为，你知道的，我在学术界……
academic. And yet I still sometimes look at myself and think, you know, are you really all that your accolades would suggest that you are? I mean, it's crazy. I honestly still struggle with that at times. It's so not crazy, Kevin. I mean, I was having, I was having imposter feelings last night because I was going to be on this podcast with you. And I was like, oh my God, what do I know about imposter syndrome? It's Dr. Copley. Yeah. No, it's real. It is very real. Well, so that raises a question of whether imposter phenomenon can ever have any positive effects. I mean, does it spur people to excel? I think you talked about that a little bit.
干得还算不错。然而，我有时还是会看着自己想：你知道的，你的荣誉真的能证明你就是那样的人吗？我的意思是，这太疯狂了。老实说，我有时仍然会为此挣扎。一点也不疯狂，凯文。我是说，昨晚我还一直在体验冒名顶替的感觉，因为我要和你在同一个播客节目里。当时我在想：天哪，我对冒名顶替综合征了解多少？那是科普利博士。是的。不，这是真的。这非常真实。那么，这就引发了一个问题：冒名顶替现象是否会产生任何积极的影响？我是说，它会不会鞭策人们追求卓越？我想你之前稍微谈过这一点。
Yeah, no, it does. I mean, I think that, you know, so for example, when I describe what has been documented as the imposter cycle, you'll see that people sort of take these sort of two paths, one of over-preparation and one of procrastination. For me, it's the path of over-preparation. So when I'm, for example, giving a talk on the imposter feelings, I prepare as though I've never given the talk before. Like, as though I haven't given dozens and dozens and dozens of the talk so much so that my partner says to me, Kevin, why are you spending so much time repairing? Like, you know this like the back of your hand.
是的，不会的，它确实会。我的意思是，我认为，举个例子，当我描述被记录下来的冒名顶替循环时，你会发现人们通常会走这两条路之一：一条是过度准备，另一条是拖延。对我来说，这是过度准备的道路。因此，举个例子，当我在做关于冒名顶替感受的演讲时，我的准备程度就像我从来没有做过这个演讲一样。就好像我没有做过几十次、上百次这个演讲一样，以至于我的伴侣对我说：“凯文，你为什么花这么多时间重新准备？你知道的，这就像你的手背一样熟悉。”
Yes, I do. But I never want people to sort of hear me and think he does not know what he's talking about. So I really overprepared. And so I think what happens with people who experience imposterism is that. that they will sort of go to the extra mile. They will work extra hard to try to, you know, sort of do well whatever the task is. And so I think in that sense, it can have a positive effect. But again, I want to make sure that you understand that oftentimes is coupled with, you know,
是的，我确实很清楚。但我绝不想让人们听了我的话后觉得他不知道自己在说什么。所以我真的做了过度准备。因此，我认为那些经历过冒名顶替心态的人会付出额外的努力。他们会加倍努力，试图把无论什么任务都做好。所以从这个意义上说，它可以产生积极的影响。但同样地，我想确保你明白，这往往与……
the negative impact that it has on one sort of well-being. Yeah. I mean, I think it's a great point. Like there's always like, as I'm sort of in recovery of my own imposterousity, I'm always working to check myself around the overwork and overfunctioning. that has done me well. I went to an Ivy League calling. I did all this things.
它对个人的幸福感产生的负面影响是交织在一起的。是的。我的意思是，我认为这是一个极好的观点。就好像，当我在逐渐摆脱自身的冒名顶替倾向时，我一直在努力自我克制，注意不要过度工作和过度发挥。这对我很有帮助。我上了常春藤盟校。我做了所有这些事情。
But I think that it has had such negative other aspects that I've come to recognize that I can be successful without thinking that everyone's going to think I'm a fraud and that those skills still exist within me, whether I think I'm a fraud or not. And then I think it's so much better if I just proceed forward as if I'm not a fraud because I think it'll be better for me a long term.
但我认为它带来了许多其他方面的负面影响，以至于我开始认识到，即使不认为每个人都认为我是个骗子，我也能获得成功，而且无论我认为自己是不是骗子，这些技能依然存在于我体内。然后我认为，如果我只是像自己不是骗子那样继续前进，情况会好得多，因为我认为长远来看这对我有好处。
And it reminds me of something my husband said to me when I was trying to be. trying to break out of my imposter syndrome. And he said, like, if you work as hard for yourself as you do for others, you're going to be unstoppable. And part of my work was around really learning how to work in that effort for myself, as opposed for proving myself, as opposed to making people like me and all this other stuff. And I did it because of things I was invested in, I was interested in that I wanted to do.
这让我想起我丈夫对我说过的一句话，当时我正试图摆脱冒名顶替综合征。他说：“如果你为自己工作就像为别人工作那样努力，你将势不可挡。”我的部分工作确实围绕着真正学习如何为自己付出努力，而不是为了证明自己，也不是为了讨好别人以及其他所有事情。我这样做是因为我投入了其中，我对它感兴趣，这是我想做的事。
I think it was a much better investment of my energy in that direction. but it's a constant battle. How is this different from just being an overachiever? Because it sounds like that's what you're describing, except that maybe you feel like there's somebody at your back, who's chasing you or criticizing you. Well, I mean, I think there's certainly a lot of overlap. I mean, being an overachiever, and in fact, what you'll see, for example,
我认为朝这个方向投入精力要划算得多，但这是一场持久的战斗。这跟单纯的好胜心强有什么区别？因为听起来你描述的就是那种状态，只不过你可能觉得背后有个人在追赶你或批评你。嗯，我的意思是，这两者肯定有很多重叠之处。作为一个争强好胜的人，事实上，你会发现，举个例子……
one of the studies that I conducted, perfectionism has been oftentimes linked to feelings of imposterous. And that's absolutely the case that individuals who have imposter feelings oftentimes will find themselves to be sort of perfectionist. And of course, we know perfectionism, the perfectionism can be both adaptive and maladaptive. And it's the maladaptive forms of perfectionism that will result in sort of feelings of imposterism being particularly harmful. And so certainly there's a strong sort of connection between sort of perfectionism and sort of, and sort of, you know, these sort of feelings that we sometimes struggle with of imposterism. And I think it's such an interesting point because I think the other thing can happen,
我进行的一项研究表明，完美主义往往与冒名顶替的感觉有关。事实确实如此，有冒名顶替感觉的人往往会发现自己具有完美主义倾向。当然，我们知道完美主义既可以是适应性的，也可以是不适应性的。正是那些不适应的完美主义形式，会导致冒名顶替的感觉变得特别有害。因此，完美主义与我们有时与之抗争的冒名顶替感之间，肯定存在着很强的联系。我认为这是一个非常有趣的观点，因为我认为另一件事也会发生……
which is true too, which is I see underachievement as well because of the perfectionism. It's like, if I can't do it perfectly, I'm not going to do it at all because then it will expose me. And so I think you can see both the overachievement and you can see underachievement. And sometimes they're in different domains or in other areas. But I think it's such an important piece around the perfectionism and how it does underlie. It can make you a great success and it can make you a great success. and it can make you a great failure. And I think it's really kind of how it sort of operates in your particular experience.
这也是真的，那就是由于完美主义，我也看到了能力不足的表现。这就好像：如果我不能完美地完成它，我就根本不做，因为那样会暴露我自己。所以我想你可以看到过度成就，也可以看到能力不足。有时它们在不同的领域或方面。但我觉得这是一个非常重要的关于完美主义的观点，以及它是如何成为基础的。它能让你取得巨大的成功，也能让你取得巨大的失败。我认为这真正取决于它在你的特定经历中是如何运作的。
So it sounds like you both have techniques for dealing with this within yourselves. What kind of advice do you give to people who are experiencing imposter phenomenon that might be holding them back? Are there techniques that they can use? I've read, for example, that group therapy is one thing that might be helpful. What else can people do if they're having this experience? Well, I mean, I'll offer one that I sort of talk about. So part of what happens with individuals who experience apostarism is that they tend to discount the really positive things that they have achieved, all of their accomplishments. And so it's helpful if you make people or if you sort of ask people to really make a concerted effort to attend to and to document all those things that they actually have done well. So for example, if you sort of ask people to really make a concerted effort to, to attend to and to document all those things that they actually have done well. So for example, if you sort of say, look, consider keeping a weekly or biweekly sort of diary. Every time that you've done something well where you've been acknowledged, where you've done a very good job, acknowledge it, just sort of
听起来你们俩都有应对内心这种状况的技巧。对于那些正在经历可能阻碍他们发展的冒名顶替现象的人，你们有什么建议？他们可以使用什么技巧吗？例如，我读到过集体治疗可能是有帮助的方法之一。如果人们正在经历这种状况，还可以做些什么？嗯，我的意思是，我会提供我经常谈论的一种方法。经历冒名顶替综合征的人身上发生的一部分情况是，他们往往会贬低自己真正取得的积极成果以及所有的成就。因此，如果你让人们或者如果你要求人们真正做出共同的努力去关注和记录他们实际上做得很好的所有事情，这会很有帮助。例如，如果你要求人们真正做出共同的努力去关注并记录他们确实做得很好的所有事情。例如，如果你建议说：考虑写周记或双周记。每当你做好了某件事，得到了认可，或者把工作做得很好时，就要认可它，把它……
documented. And then sort of come back and review that because what ends up happening is you'll see, you know what, I actually have done a very good job on, you know, fill in the blank on this test, on this task, on this, you know, sort of project. Because when you're suffering from imposterism, it becomes very easy to minimize or to discount all those things. You just don't even acknowledge or sometimes you just forget. So attending to those things and making a concerted effort to document them and to revisit them periodically to see, hey, you know what, I have actually done, you know, better than what I give myself credit for.
记录下来。然后回过头来复盘，因为最终发生的情况是你会看到：你知道吗，我在填空处——这个测试、这个任务、这个项目上——其实真的做得很好。因为当你饱受冒名顶替综合征折磨时，你很容易将所有这些事情最小化或贬低。你甚至都不会去认可它们，有时甚至会忘记。所以，关注这些事情，并做出共同的努力去记录它们，然后定期重温，看看“嘿，你知道吗，我其实做得比自己想象的要好”。
Yeah, and I think, you know, my book is like all the interventions that have been in the literature and then and sort of also things that I've seen work in my practice. And I think the other, I would definitely agree with Dr. Coughley on that. And I think in addition to dealing with your automatic negative thoughts, you know, learning that certain thoughts are triggered by the imposter syndrome and how do you combat the automatic negative thought and don't just believe it and fall into the cycle of overworking or procrastinating. Working on yourself care, oftentimes when we have imposter syndrome, we put ourselves
是的，而且我认为，我的书里包含了文献中出现过的所有干预措施，以及我在实践中看到确实有效的那些方法。我认为另一——我绝对同意科克利博士的看法。除了应对你的自动消极思维之外，还要认识到某些思维是由冒名顶替综合征触发的，以及如何与自动消极思维作斗争，不要盲目相信它们，也不要陷入过度工作或拖延的循环中。努力做好自我照顾，通常当我们患有冒名顶替综合征时，我们会把自我照顾……
at the bottom of the list of who we care about or who we take care of, who we spend time on, really learning how to prioritize that because one of the biggest outcomes from imposter syndrome, Impostalgia syndrome is burnout. And so how do you help avoid chronic burnout? How do you deal with it? How do you recognize and structure self-care? I think oftentimes also we're caught up in very rigid roles around our imposter syndrome. We know how to be the helper. We know how to be the go-to person. We know how to be certain things, but we don't know how to expand outside of those roles. So how do we learn how to ask for help? How do we learn how to widen our role sets? And also building community around this. We often struggle with this alone. And how do you build
放在我们关心的、照顾的或花时间的对象名单的最底部，真正学会如何优先处理这一点，因为冒名顶替综合征最大的结果之一就是职业倦怠。那么，如何帮助避免长期的职业倦怠？如何应对它？如何识别并构建自我照顾？我认为很多时候，我们也陷入了围绕冒名顶替综合征的非常僵化的角色中。我们知道如何成为那个提供帮助的人，我们知道如何成为那个随叫随到的人，我们知道如何成为某种特定的人，但我们不知道如何超出这些角色的范围去拓展。那么，我们如何学会寻求帮助？我们如何学会扩大我们的角色组合？以及围绕这一点建立社群。我们经常独自与此抗争。你如何建立……
community around you that can support you as you kind of recover from this experience. So I think like those are some of them I would also add. Is imposterism something that tends to affect younger people, college students especially, or is that just because that's the research that's out there right now? But by the time people are more established in their careers, does it, does it taper off? I mean, do you just grow and become more confident or do you really have to keep working on it for your whole life. I mean, I think there are ways to kind of minimize it and to get, I always say, isn't it going to go away? Probably not. But can you turn the dial down on it so quietly that you can't even hear it or barely hear it? Yes. And it depends on sort of your trigger and when you're
一个能够支持你的社群，在你从这种经历中恢复时给予你支持。所以我想这些也是我会补充的一些建议。冒名顶替倾向是倾向于影响年轻人，尤其是大学生，还是仅仅因为目前的研究所涉及的群体是这样？当人们在职业生涯中更加稳定时，它会逐渐消退吗？我的意思是，你会随着成长而变得更加自信，还是真的必须一辈子不断与之抗争？我的意思是，有办法将其最小化并加以克服。我总是说：“它不会消失吗？”可能不会。但你能把它的音量调小到听不见或几乎听不见的程度吗？是的。这取决于你的触发因素以及你何时……
getting triggered. But I would say like some of the early dates, there's some data out there that suggests that does not get better with time. There was a study by KPMG in 2020 that showed that female executives had a rate of 75% imposter syndrome. So that's higher numbers. than we generally see. So part of the, I think part of the understanding of that is as we become more visible, have more responsibility, have more on the line, it can sometimes make our imposter syndrome worse because there's just a greater stakes at hand. If we lose this, it's a bigger deal. So it can be exacerbated over time depending on responsibility, but I don't know if it's, it's, if there are cohort effects, but I would, I definitely, I'm very interested in sort of more research in the field of
被触发。但我会说，在早期的一些数据中，有一些数据表明它不会随着时间的推移而好转。毕马威在2020年进行的一项研究显示，女性高管患冒名顶替综合征的比率为75%。所以这个数字比我们通常看到的要高。因此，我认为对此的理解部分在于，随着我们变得更加引人注目、承担更多责任、面临更多利害关系，它有时会使我们的冒名顶替综合征恶化，因为手头的利害关系更大了。如果我们失去这个，事情就大条了。因此，根据责任的不同，它可能会随着时间的推移而加剧，我不知道这是否存在群体效应，但我非常对该领域的更多研究感兴趣……
imposter syndrome. But yeah, no, I would agree with what Dr. Orba Alston said. I'm not aware of any research that has examined cohort effects. But as I sort of shared anecdotally, you know, I, you know, I'm a 50-year-old man who's, you know, reasonably successful in my profession and still have had, you know, experiences where I struggle with imposterism. So I would just sort of say that there's probably not a lot of data that would suggest that there are, you know, sort of these profound sort of age differences. Although there may be, I'm just, I just, I'm not. I'm not, not aware of any research. But I would agree with Dr. Orbi-Alson that I think that people can certainly learn to sort of dial down those imposter feelings with sort of age and experience and maturity.
冒名顶替综合征。不过，是的，我同意奥尔比-奥尔森博士的观点。据我所知，没有任何研究探讨过群体效应。但正如我之前以轶事形式分享的那样，我是一个50岁的男人，在职业生涯中算得上相当成功，却依然经历过与冒名顶替心态作斗争的时刻。所以我想说的是，可能并没有太多数据表明存在这种深刻的年龄差异。尽管可能存在，我只是……我只是不知道，我不知道有任何这样的研究。但我同意奥尔比-奥尔森博士的看法，我认为人们确实可以随着年龄、经验和成熟度学会调低那些冒名顶替的感受。
At least we hope that that's the case. So what is the relationship between imposter phenomenon and other mental health challenges that you mentioned earlier like anxiety or depression? Well, I mean, the relationship is that there has been a consistent finding that imposter feelings are associated with increased feelings of anxiety or symptoms of anxiety and depression. I mean, every study that I've ever conducted and every study that I've ever seen reported shows this association. So, yeah, I mean, I think that's, I think we're pretty confident in the saying that if you
至少我们希望如此。那么，冒名顶替现象与你刚才提到的其他心理健康挑战（如焦虑或抑郁）之间有什么关系？嗯，我的意思是，它们之间的关系在于，有一项持续的发现表明：冒名顶替的感觉与焦虑和抑郁的情绪或症状的增加有关。我的意思是，我做过的每一项研究以及我所见过的每一项报告的研究都显示了这种关联。所以，是的，我的意思是，我认为对此我们相当确信，如果你……
are experiencing, you know, imposterism, you are likely going to be also experiencing feelings of, you know, symptoms of anxiety and some depression. And so if you treat those symptoms, then does that help? the imposter phenomenon? Not necessarily. They can be different, right? I think you, you know, one of the things that I've seen, though, is people who have treated their, you know, anxiety with, like, CBT skills or can use some of the similar CBT skills around their imposter syndrome. So I think you can, the skills that you're learning are transferable, but I think you have to tackle the specific, you know, experiences of imposter syndrome around this experience of being a fraud and it being competent.
当你经历冒名顶替综合征时，你很可能同时也会经历焦虑和一些抑郁的症状。所以，如果你治疗这些症状，那会有所帮助吗？能解决冒名顶替现象吗？不一定。它们可能是不同的，对吧？我认为我所看到的情况之一是，有些人通过比如CBT（认知行为疗法）技巧治疗了他们的焦虑，或者可以将一些类似的CBT技巧应用到他们的冒名顶替综合征中。所以我觉得你可以，你学到的技巧是可迁移的，但我认为你必须解决围绕这种“自己是个骗子”以及“自己能力不足”的特定冒名顶替综合征体验。
One of the things that I think is really important for me and my work has been to help people to identify the early experiences that were the foundation for why this imposter syndrome became what it became, whether it was rigid roles in childhood or whether it was family dynamics that were common. I think that has been really helpful for people because I think they start to realize, oh, this thing didn't come from nowhere. And the reason why I'm triggered by particular things today has a history. make sense to me as opposed to this thing came out of nowhere and I know I don't know how to stop it. I think it has, it gives people agency in a sense of like, oh, I get it now. This didn't come from absolutely nowhere. Yeah, no, if I could build on that, I mean, when you read, you know, some of the early work by Clans and Iams, they talk about both having internal factors and the external environment
对我以及我的工作而言，非常重要的一点是帮助人们识别那些最初的经历，正是这些经历构成了这种冒名顶替综合征演变成今天这样的基础，无论是童年时期僵化的角色，还是常见的家庭动力。我认为这对人们真的很有帮助，因为他们开始意识到，哦，这东西不是凭空出现的。而且我今天被特定事情触发是有历史原因的。这对我来说说得通，而不是这东西来得莫名其妙，我甚至不知道该如何阻止它。我认为这赋予了人们自主权，让他们有一种“哦，我现在明白了，这绝不是凭空产生的”的感觉。是的，如果我在此基础上补充一点，当你们阅读克兰斯和伊姆斯（Clans and Iams）早期的一些著作时，他们谈到了内部因素和外部环境
sort of factors in terms of contributing to how the impossible phenomenon was created. So, for example, regarding internal factors, what they noticed amongst the women that they were working with was the women reported receiving messages about being competent in all these different areas. You know, you're so skilled interpersonal. You're so skilled, I mean, in all these other areas, but not anything related to their intelligence. So they started to at some point think, well, I'm good in these other ways that are more sort of socially related, but no one is ever telling me that I'm, you know, naturally intelligent or that I'm intelligent. So they started to internalize those messages. And then in terms of the external environment, being told, for example, that they, in fact, were really smart, very competent, superior even. But then finding that even though I'm being told this, I'm struggling to meet these expectations.
这两类因素共同促成了冒名顶替现象的产生。举个例子，关于内部因素，他们注意到在他们合作的女性当中，这些女性反映她们收到的信息是关于她们在各个不同领域都很有能力。你知道的，你在人际交往中很有技巧。你在所有这些其他领域都很有技巧，但唯独没有任何与她们的智力有关的评价。所以在某种程度上，她们开始认为，好吧，我在这些更偏向社交的其他方面很擅长，但从来没人告诉我，你知道的，我是天生聪明的，或者我是聪明的。于是她们开始内化这些信息。然后就外部环境而言，比如有人告诉她们，事实上她们真的很聪明、非常有能力、甚至是优秀的。但随后她们发现，尽管别人这么对我说，我在努力达到这些期望时却感到很吃力。
You know, I'm trying to sort of live up to what people are saying that I am, but not being able to or feel like they're not being able to. And so both those sort of internal factors in the external environment were reported by, you know, clients and I am as sort of contributing to the creation of imposter feelings. What is the role of institutions and leaders like professors or managers to address imposter syndrome? We've been talking a fair amount about what individuals can do themselves, but is there something that institutions, companies can do to recognize and help people address it? Where do I get started on this? I think, you know, companies benefit from this. Right? Because if you are over functioning and overworking and overperforming, they're benefiting.
你知道的，我试图去达到别人所说的那种人，但却做不到，或者觉得自己做不到。因此，克兰斯和伊姆斯指出，正是这些内部因素和外部环境共同导致了冒名顶替情绪的产生。那么，机构和领导者（比如教授或经理）在解决冒名顶替综合征方面扮演什么角色呢？我们一直在讨论相当多关于个人自己能做的事情，但有没有什么事是机构和公司可以做的，来识别并帮助人们解决这个问题呢？我该从哪里开始着手？我认为，公司其实从中受益了。对吧？因为如果你过度运转、过度工作、过度表现，他们是最大的受益者。
They're in essence sometimes getting two or three people for the price of one. And so I do think it is there's a lot of inside the system that encourages this level of impossible. I actually was doing a training recently and someone was saying, look, I'm working on trying to have more balance in my life. And I want to do an adequate job. And I ask my manager, can I just do an adequate job and not do exceeds expectations? but then their comp, their comp was, like there's ties to their comp and their bonus structure that if they don't exceed, they don't get anything. So if you just do a good enough job at your job, which we're always telling people who have
从本质上讲，他们有时只花一份薪水就能得到两到三个人的产出。所以我确实认为，系统内部有很多鼓励这种程度的冒名顶替现象的机制。其实我最近在做培训时，有人说：“听着，我正在努力让我的生活更有平衡感。我想做一份合格的工作。我问我的经理，我能不能只做一份合格的工作，而不是追求‘超出预期’？”但随后他们的薪酬，他们的薪酬结构是与绩效紧密挂钩的，如果他们没有达到“超出预期”，他们就什么也得不到。所以，如果你在工作中只做到足够好——我们总是对那些有
perfectionism, like, it's focus on the good enough. Like, if you just do good enough, you don't get additional compensation. So you have to constantly be exceeding to be able to reach certain comp norms. I do think there's a lot in our systems that really have to change so that we don't reinforce force this. Don't burn people out and use them for what they have and then discard them. We have to be more thoughtful about the workers in our system and how we take care of them and how we create longevity for their careers. And I think there's a lot we can do around management and organizations to change these systems that are reinforcing it, you know, ordinarily. Yeah, no, absolutely.
完美主义倾向的人说，比如，要专注于“足够好”。如果你只是做到足够好，你就不会获得额外的报酬。所以你必须不断地超越自我，才能达到某种薪酬标准。我确实认为我们的系统里有很多东西真的必须改变，这样我们才不会强化这种现象。不要把人们燃尽，榨干他们的价值然后抛弃他们。我们必须对系统中的工作者以及如何照顾他们、如何为他们的职业生涯创造长久性有更多深思熟虑的考量。我认为在管理和组织方面，我们可以做很多事情来改变这些不断强化该现象的体制，这本来就是常规操作。是的，绝对如此。
And the other sort of suggesting that I would make, and this is a more difficult one because it really speaks to culture is creating an environment where it's okay to acknowledge that one has made a mistake, to acknowledge that one is not perfect. And this should come from the leaders, from the people, the managers. And this is a bit, imagine, imagine what it would be like for an employee to have a manager to sort of say, you know what, I messed up. I dropped the ball here. I made a mistake. And, you know, it's okay. You know, we're human. Imagine the impact that that would have on employees when their managers acknowledge that sometimes they make mistakes as well.
我提出的另一个建议——这是一个更困难的建议，因为它真正触及了文化层面——是创建一个环境，在这个环境中，承认自己犯了错误、承认自己并不完美是可以被接受的。这应该来自于领导者、来自于那些身为经理的人。这有点……想象一下，对于一个员工来说，如果他们的经理说：“你知道吗，我搞砸了。我在这里失误了。我犯了一个错误。而且，没关系。你知道的，我们都是凡人。”想象一下，当经理们承认他们有时也会犯错时，这对员工会产生什么样的影响。
Yeah, I'll take it one step further, which is like, and then do like a post-mortem on the mistake so everyone can learn from it. Exactly. You know? Exactly. And have such more of a growth mindset perspective as opposed to a fixed mindset perspective about people's capacities and capabilities. Now, exactly.
是的，我会再进一步，也就是针对这个错误做一次“事后复盘”，这样每个人都能从中吸取教训。完全正确。你知道吗？没错。并且要以一种成长型思维的视角，而不是固定型思维的视角来看待人们的能力和潜能。现在，确实如此。
Now, we all know that changing culture is easier said than done. culture tends to be among the most difficult things to sort of try to change. But if that could happen, it could go such a long ways. I mean, if companies are really serious about being responsive to the needs of their employees, this is one of the things that they absolutely should do. Yeah. The well-being of their employees are a lot of talk about well-being and mental health. And these, there are correlates to imposter syndrome to mental health outcomes,
现在，我们都知道改变文化说起来容易做起来难。文化往往是最难以试图改变的事物之一。但如果这能够发生，它将会产生深远的影响。我是说，如果公司真的认真对待员工的需求并做出回应，这绝对是他们应该做的事情之一。是的。员工的福祉——有很多关于福祉和心理健康的讨论。这些与冒名顶替综合征和心理健康结果之间存在关联，
burnout, depression, anxiety. If you want to reduce that in your staff, reduce some of the ways. in which you are organized to encourage them to do this, you know. Well, this has been really interesting. I think you've offered some good advice to people who may be experiencing the phenomenon, and certainly it doesn't appear that it has held you to back in any way in life. I think you've been quite successful, and I've enjoyed spending some time with you. So thank you.
比如倦怠、抑郁、焦虑。如果你想在员工中减少这些现象，就得减少那种鼓励他们这样做的组织方式。好了，这次访谈真的非常有趣。我认为你为那些可能正在经历这种现象的人提供了一些很好的建议，而且这显然并没有在生活中以任何方式阻碍你取得成就。我认为你相当成功，我也很享受和你在一起的时光。谢谢你。
Thank you. Likewise. I've enjoyed it, too. It's been lovely. For our listeners, you can read more about imposter phenomenon in the June issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. Go to www.apa.org slash monitor or look for a link in our show notes. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you're so inclined, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
谢谢你。彼此彼此。我也很享受。非常愉快。对于我们的听众，您可以在美国心理协会（APA）杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）六月号上阅读更多关于冒名顶替现象的文章。请访问 www.apa.org/monitor 或在我们的节目文稿中寻找链接。您可以在 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《心理学与你》（Speaking of Psychology）节目。如果您愿意，请给我们留个评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，请发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连写，@apa.org。《心理学与你》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪恩（Chris Kondyenne）。谢谢收听。我是美国心理协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。